This is a big moment. Dean has never,
ever had cinnamon chicken,
and nor have I ever made it before.
With a lot of assistance,
but I think we've. We've gotten there.
It looks good. Yeah. No.
Oh, my god.
It looks fantastic. Smells amazing.
So should we try? We're about to have a big moment.
Really good.
Hmm. What do you rate it? Oh,
you know, I'm thinking there's always room to go,
so I'm gonna give it, like,
an 8. I'm gonna give it an 8 out of 10,
but without knowing exactly what the range on this is.
So I'm thinking if we do this again,
we can make it better. I'm not sure what we would do to make it better.
I think I am gonna put a little cayenne on it just to see,
because, of course,
that's the way I supposedly experienced it for the first time.
I could probably put more on,
because I barely. Okay,
now I'm getting it in the aftertaste.